[Music]
goal-setting is fascinating because it's
sort of a broken process in many
respects this is the way a goal works
you say to yourself when I achieve
whatever the thing is that's how I'll
know I'll have this I'll have succeeded
and I'm gonna do everything I can to get
to that point as quickly as possible
what that means is you exist in a
failure State for a long time until you
reach that goal if it's a long-range
goal and so as you evaluate your process
all you get is the negative feedback of
not having achieved that goal perhaps as
you move closer to it there's some
positive feedback but if the goal is
really the end state that you're seeking
out there's a lot of failure before you
get there and now here's the thing when
you do get there it's a massive
anticlimax
so there are people who achieve the
highest highs people who achieve the
highest highs in athletics in business
and if you talk to them and you destroy
it you ask them to describe what it's
like to reach their goals they say
things like I got there and it was an
incredible anticlimax I the minute I got
there I had to start something new I had
to find a new goal and that's partly
because there's something really
unsatisfying about the moment of
reaching the goal unless it has its own
benefits that come from reaching the
goal if it's just a sort of signpost
that doesn't do much for us it doesn't
nourish us psychologically and what that
ends up meaning is that we have to try
and find something new so really if you
look at life as a series of goals which
for many of us it is it's a period of
being unsuccessful in achieving the goal
then hitting the goal then feeling like
you haven't really got much from that
goal going to the next one and it's a
sort of series of escalating goals a
really good example of this is say smart
watches or fitbit's or exercise watches
people when they get those watches a lot
of them hit on the number 10,000 I want
to walk 10,000 steps when you do that
the thing will beep you'll feel pretty
good about it for a minute but then that
feels a little hollow and the goal
escalates over time people will describe
going from 10 to 11 to 12 to 14 thousand
steps to the point where they're moving
through injuries through stress-related
injuries because the goal is there they
respond to the goal more than they do to
their internal click cues and and
basically there's something really
unfulfilled about that the reason the
goal keeps escalating and becoming more
and more intense
is because when they achieve the goal
they don't actually get anything for
that achievement and so goals generally
I think are in many ways broken
processes I think part of the problem
with goals is that they don't tell you
how to get to where you're going a
better thing to do is to use a system so
the idea behind a system rather than a
goal is that a system is saying things
like I'm a writer
my goal is to finish writing this book
but I'm not not gonna think about it
that way eventually I'll have a hundred
thousand words but what my my system
will be that for an hour every morning I
will sit in front of my computer screen
and I will type it doesn't matter what
that looks like
I'm not going to evaluate the number of
words I'm not going to set some
benchmarks some artificial number or
benchmark that I should reach what I'm
gonna do is just say here's my system an
hour a day in front of the screen will
do what I can
BAM and the thing is every time you set
a system and you stick to it you're
achieving something instead of a goal
that you're failing essentially for long
periods of time until you reach the goal
you're succeeding every day as long as
you adhere to your system and you end up
getting to the same place but that
framing is so much more effective it
gives you the kind of positive feedback
you seek and a system is is kind of
geared towards psychological well-being
this is the thing I need to do to feel
good about the way I'm moving through
the world towards whatever end state I'm
looking for goals don't do that
they just set signposts that you're
supposed to look at from afar and move
towards systems are a much more useful
way of engaging with the world towards
certain ends and certain outcomes
[Music]
you